There are urban legends surrounding every
walk of life and the world of movies is no
different.
Some are rebuffed - like the supposed "ghost
child" on the set of Three Men and a Baby
turning out to be a cardboard cut-out of Ted
Danson - while others remain a mystery.In
some cases, mysterious events happening on
and around movie sets have led people to believe
that the sets in question were actually cursed.
Strange occurrences, freak accidents and even,
in some cases, the deaths of crew and cast
members, have resulted in such conclusions.It's
an often tragic topic, but it's certainly
an interesting one - and it's what this video
is all about.
Here are ten movies with shockingly cursed
sets.
The Passion of the Christ
Movies that deal with religion are notorious
for having cursed sets and none dealt with
the subject more controversially than Mel
Gibson's The Passion of the Christ - and it
was the movie's star Jim Caviezel, who played
Jesus, that suffered the supposed curse most
severely in this case.Caviezel was struck
by lightning during filming, as was assistant
director Jan Michelini on two occasions.
But Caviezel also obtained lacerations during
whipping scenes, dislocated his shoulder while
performing the crucifixion scenes, suffered
with hypothermia, and contracted both a lung
infection and pneumonia.
He also suffered painful skin infections from
the makeup that was used to depict his gruesome
injuries in the movie.
Poor guy!
Poltergeist
1982's Poltergeist was notorious for its supposedly
cursed set.
Some people believe that "the Poltergeist
curse" was caused by the fact that real skeletons
were used during filming but, regardless of
what caused it, there's no doubt that the
events surrounding the movie - and indeed
the entire franchise - were both creepy and
absolutely tragic.In the six year period between
the three films, cast members claimed to be
haunted by ghosts in their own homes and four
of the main actors died.
Most infamously and tragically, young Heather
O'Rourke died four months before the third
film was released thanks to a botched operation.
Additionally, Dominique Dunne was murdered
by her boyfriend soon after the first film
was released, Julian Beck died of stomach
cancer whilst filming the second film, and
Will Sampson died soon after filming it due
to kidney transplant complications.
And remember that creepy clown toy in the
first movie?
Due to a malfunction in the prop's mechanics,
it really did choke young actor Oliver Robbins
- though he did survive the incident.
Rosemary's Baby
Rosemary's Baby is one of the most disturbing
and iconic horror movies of all time, and
a supposed curse on the movie's set led to
some horrific things happening to the cast
and crew.
The movie's producer even claimed that “The
story of Rosemary’s Baby was happening in
real life.
Witches, all of them, were casting their spell,
and I was becoming one of the principal players.”Director
Roman Polanski's pregnant wife, Sharon Tate,
was murdered by Charlie Manson's clan a year
after the movie's release - with the murder
scene being one of the most sickening ever
witnessed.
Producer William Castle suffered from sudden
kidney failure after receiving hate mail about
the film, and the film's composer Krzysztof
Komeda died of a sudden blood clot on his
brain - something that was eerily reminiscent
of a character in the movie itself.
The Exorcist
Given the subject matter of the infamously
controversial 1973 movie The Exorcist, is
it any wonder that the movie's set was said
to be cursed?
Not only did strange and terrible things happen
to the movie's cast and crew, but even audiences
were affected by the supposed curse.Where
do we even start here?
Well, the movie's set inexplicably burned
down and delayed filming for six weeks.
Star Ellen Burstyn hurt her back and missed
weeks of filming whilst bedbound.
Actor Jack McGowran died suddenly just one
week after he finished filming his role in
the movie.
Half of the crew were struck down with sunstroke
or dysentery whilst filming on location in
Iraq.
A night-watchman and a special effects expert
died during the making of the film and, ultimately,
things got so bad that the director recruited
a priest to exorcise the set.
During screenings of the movie, viewers blacked
out, vomited, had heart attacks, and one woman
even miscarried.
The Amityville Horror
The Amityville Horror is supposedly a true
story and the original movie based on it - which
was made in 1979 - spawned a number of sequels
and a 2005 remake.
It was the sets of the original and its aforementioned
reboot that were supposedly cursed.The star
of the original, James Brolin, wasn't overly
keen on the idea of starring in the movie
and only accepted the role after a strange
event occurred.
He was reading the script in the early hours
of the morning when a pair of his pants suddenly
fell off a hanger, causing him to leap out
of his chair in terror.
Years later, Just before filming was due to
start on the 2005 remake, a dead body washed
up on shore near the movie's set, and Ryan
Reynolds, the remake's star, has claimed that
members of the crew kept waking up at a quarter
past three each morning while filming.
This was also the time that the real murders
that influenced the story took place.
Twilight Zone: The Movie
In 1983, a movie based on The Twilight Zone
television series was released.
It was in anthology form, with John Landis,
Steven Spielberg and George Miller each directing
a different segment - and the movie was believed
to be cursed.In one scene involving a helicopter,
a nearby air mortar blew off the chopper’s
tail.
It crashed into the river below, severing
the heads of one of the movie's stars - Victor
Morrow - and a Vietnamese child actor called
Myca Dinh Le, and crushing another Vietnamese
child actor named Renee Shin-Yi Chen to death.
Both of the children had been hired illegally
by the producers.
Eerily, the film’s concept artist had included
a burnt-out helicopter in the middle of the
river in one of his sketches, foreshadowing
the details of the accident.
Even more eerily, a year before his death,
Victor Morrow had taken out a $5 million life
insurance policy after having a premonition
that he would die in a helicopter crash.
The Crow
1994's The Crow is one of the most underrated
superhero movies of all time - people forget
just how good it was, given how low key it
was in comparison to the superhero movies
of today - but the number of horror incidents
on its set would suggest that the movie was
cursed.The first day of filming set the tone,
when a crew member's crane ran into a power
cable, resulting in him suffering burns on
90% of his body.
From that point on, a construction driver
drove a screwdriver through his own hand,
a set sculptor destroyed the props room with
his car, and a storm destroyed most of the
set itself.
Of course, the most tragic occurence was the
death of the movie's star - Brandon Lee - who
was shot dead by accident during filming.
Rather spookily, the event mirrored a scene
from his father Bruce's movie Game of Death,
in which an actor is shot dead when gangsters
replaced a prop bullet with a real one.
Bruce would die before completing that movie.
The Wizard of Oz
The Wizard of Oz was released in 1939 - long
before safety regulations even existed on
movie sets, let alone before they were anywhere
near as strict as they are today - so the
accidents that happened on the movie's set
could be put down to that, but there were
indeed quite a few accidents and many believe
that they must have occurred due to the set
being cursed.The original Tin Man, Buddy Ebsen,
was almost killed by an allergic reaction
to the aluminum powder used for his makeup,
resulting in him being replaced by Jack Haley.
Margaret Hamilton, who played the Wicked Witch,
caught on fire and refused to perform any
more pyrotechnic scenes thereafter, and the
little dog who played Toto broke a paw.
However, that strange thing appearing to swing
around in the background of one scene wasn't
a munchkin actor who hung himself, as some
people suggested – it was merely a bird.
The Omen
The Omen is another horror movie that dealt
with religion as a theme - an apparently sure-fire
way to encourage weird things to happen to
the people involved - and, sure enough, that's
exactly what happened during and after the
filming of this 1976 classic.There was an
animal handler on the movie's set helping
to organise the scene in which a baboon goes
into a frenzy, and he was killed by a tiger
the the day after that scene was filmed.
Then, soon after the movie was released, the
special effects director was involved in a
car crash that tragically killed his girlfriend
- she was decapitated in an eerily similar
way to one of the characters in the film.
Even more bizarre was the fact that a sign
by the wreckage supposedly read "Ommen 66km".
But the absolute creepiest thing about the
accident was that it happened on Friday the
13th of August, 1976.
It's enough to send a shudder down your spine.
The Matrix
Most of the movies on this list are from the
horror genre - which often makes the fact
that the sets were cursed even creepier - but
that's not always the case.
1999's The Matrix is a sci-fi classic, but
events that occurred during production led
people to believe in something called "The
Curse of the Matrix".Two cast members - Aaliyah
and Gloria Foster - died during filming (in
a plane crash and from diabetes respectively),
Keanu Reeves' real-life relationship broke
down after the birth of his stillborn child
during production, Reeves himself had to spend
his own money to ensure production continued
after mounting costs threatened to bring it
to a halt, a number of the special-effects
houses commissioned to produce individual
shots went bust - and that's not even everything,
but we'd be talking all day if we tried to
cover it all.
Thanks for watching our video about shockingly
cursed movie sets.
Did you enjoy this video?
Do you know of any other movie sets that were
supposedly cursed?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.